bonjour et bien avant d'aller rejoindre
dans sa cuisine celui que vous attendez
tous mon ami pierrot branche financière
je voudrais moi d'abord vous poser une
question est ce que vous connaissez la a
à a
et bien c'est l'association amicale des
amateurs d'authentiqués andouillettes
c'est très sérieux institut
d'associations qui est intégrée par des
confrères journalistes qui a une
vingtaine d'années pour défendre
l'andouillette artisanale traditionnelle
parce que eh oui avec comme beaucoup
d'autres produits artisanaux
c'est un jet est menacé par des
fabrications industrielles
alors heureusement il ya encore des
îlots de résistance quand même et qu'est
ce que vous allez me dire qu'est ce que
l'authentic andouillettes c'est bien ça
dépend ça dépend des régions
ça dépend des villes ça dépend aussi des
charcutiers 1 par exemple dans le nord
il ya deux ans douillette très célèbre
qui sont aujourd'hui yattara si
l'andouillette de cambrai eh bien elles
sont ces andouilles est là à base de
fraise de veau c'est à dire cela la
membrane qui entoure intestins du mot
alors que dans d'autres régions
eh bien il ya du porc qui vient
s'associer à la fraise de vous voyez que
tout ça est très différent selon les
localités mais pour en savoir plus sur
l'andouillette d'arras par exemple eh
bien je vous invite à suivre
valérie dernière c'est d'y ans chez un
charcutier d'arras tout ce que vous avez
toujours voulu savoir sur l'andouillette
d'arras
sans jamais oser le demander nous sommes
dans la charcuterie de bernard brouillet
doctoresse andouillette aaaaa est
aujourd'hui dans le secret de son
laboratoire il a réalisé sous vos yeux
la spécialité de sa ville commençons par
l'essentiel la fraise de veau ou si vous
préférez l'estomac pour faire une bonne
enduit net il faut de la bonne prise au
mot bien fraîche car c'est ça qui fait
la spécificité de l'andouillette d'arras
la fraise de veau les aux antilles est
celle de lyon 2 3 sont faites à base de
fraises de porte
ensuite il y à l'assaisonnement ici les
échalotes du sel du poivre un peu de
muscade et quelques drames d'une poudre
dans la composition des connu que de
bernard bros
la fabrication de l'andouillette ça les
connaît chez eux cet art se transmet de
génération en génération
je connais pas très bien le la date
exacte on a commencé à faire des
sandwiches et qu'on perd 79 des
fabriques je vois c'est et ma grand mère
après c'était mon père c'était beaucoup
maintenant c'est le fils de zinedine
zidane en améliorant louis on améliore
toujours du bien sûr
non non non
mais mon grand père lorsqu'il a débuté
vous pêchez à la main maintenant je vais
la machine sachez au passage nos âmes
que les hommes qui fabriquent les
onduleurs sont les mains un très très
douce ça c'est une confidence d'ebrié
père et fils quant à vous messieurs vous
savez ce qu'il vous reste à faire
l'andouillette désormais n'a plus de
secrets pour vous
ah si j'oubliais encore un détail la
cuisson avant la vente deux heures au
four dans une bière avec ça laurier et
oignons
voilà vous avez même le prix des
andouillettes d'arras je suis bien
d'ailleurs que à arras même en percute y
est il ya des petites variantes dans la
recette se perchant un autre circuit qui
fusent excellente andouillettes lui mais
de l'oignon la place de l'échalote et
puis mes du persil dans plus bon à
cambrai à parlons-en parce que pierrot
c'est d'andouillette deux camps mais
rappelons qu'elle est très bon dans les
rues de saint géry voyez des changes et
à la fraise de veau à la fraise de veau
également alors ce sont des
andouillettes sont de cambrai qui font
un peu comme à arras et disons que c'est
une spécialité vraiment du nord c'est la
vraie en juillet de cambrai
alors comment vous nous a préparé
aujourd'hui alors on va faire il n'y a
pas tellement de recettes pour les
andouillettes on a deux recettes
exactement qu'on va faire aujourd'hui on
veut en faire une à la moutarde que vous
commencez déjà que je suis en train de
faire regarder chanter maison douillette
à la moutarde que j'ai des veillées dans
le vinaigre et j'enroule dans la
chapelure on va l'enfer 1h boyata la
moutarde et une autre recette tout ça
l'andouillette à la flambée au genièvre
à le regarder
donc là on enduit on badigeonne on
badigeonne de mouthe à la moutarde monte
au nez oreilles des fans
oui je vois oui et qu'est-ce qu'il vous
faudra alors comme nous en juillet de
montcuq rend fou il suffira simplement
de faire une petite crème une petite
sauce avec la crème fraîche
la moutarde les échalotes et le vin
blanc vous avez mis un peu de matière
grasse dans le terminal en stand huile
pour pas qu'elle s'accroche parce
qu'après l'andouillette va évidemment
décrocher beaucoup de graisse donc on
n'a pas de mettre trop de graisse voilà
et je vais mettre un soupçon travaux sur
la peau la coloration vraiment laurie un
soupçon oui et je le mets appourchaux
oublié d'allumer votre tour thomas donné
il était là alors laïta à 200 degrés à
peu près seul regret et l'état pur show
à 200 degrés puisque avec la chapelure
elle va donc fuir et se gonfler pendant
ce temps la pierre pour gagner du temps
on va accueillir nos en doublettes qu'on
peut aussi faire à la fois l'hymne donc
deuxième recette
voilà pareil on met un soupçon d'huile
en plus c'est une poêle qui n'accroche
pas donc on doit vraiment
et on va chauffer un peu cette ville
qu'est ce qu'il faudra comme elle est
incroyablement la cuy entre des mois
vous avez valeur une fois que l'embout y
est gratuite
oui on va là dégraisser c'est à dire
enlever la graisse on va acheter formé
au genièvre ensuite met un peu de crème
fraîche un petit peu d'échalotes
quelques baies de genièvre que j'étais
trempé regarder dans tous les cuisines
de restaurant ce mois il ya des baies de
genièvre qui trempe on m'attaque notre
andouillettes au genièvre et on remettra
un petit morceau de beurre pour lier la
sauce et l'andouillette sera parfaite et
vous verrez c'est très bien et je pose
mes l'andouillette alors dans la poêle
c'est pas comme aux fous la température
elle va monter tout doucement tout
doucement tout doucement tout aussi faux
pas pour l'affairé pour ce n'est pas
pareil comme ça qu'une somme de tous les
côtés alors à la poêle sans les malmener
sans les flics et alors c'est la grande
question faut-il appliquer ou oui ou non
moi je refuse pas en principe ça va bien
mais les fautes arrive que sur
qu'attendu y est y en a une qui claque
on sait quoi pourtant rien à faire voilà
pierre les andouillettes le jardinier 38
regarde les voiles et oui vous allez
bien coloré tu voi son impeccable et il
y en a trois avec avid à une tissu
légèrement bon bah c'est la nature il y
avait cet avis il y avait peut-être un
petit boyau un peu plus à quelque part à
la limite entre les manger comme ça on
peut les manger comme ça donc ça ce
serait naturel on les voit comme ça avec
une pomme au four in frites ou des
salades on peut les manger comme ça mais
là on va la faire don au génial je vais
simplement lever votre iphone excellente
grèce de fans ils n'ont pas non mais ça
va pas passer très chaud mais après
c'est vrai il n'y a pas de problème
voilà et je vais donc les flancs d'un
joli m
alors attention jeunesse encore voit la
grèce va c'est goûter ouais
on arrose généreusement attention mais
j'ai un jeu tout simplement ultime tenir
le coffret intitulé chaleur mais peu de
jeunes hier que j'ai vraiment peu de
genièvre
enfin des baies de genièvre trempé dans
le jus lièvre et je veux même si vous
deviez vous savez très bien imprimer et
un soupçon de beurre avec mes doigts
en plus de la cram un petit soupçon bird
pour liés à l'alcool et les acières
rachetées selon belge aujourd'hui je
fais le service ne peuvent mais en
juillet oui c'est sûr les assiettes
si votre salle pour faire joli on va en
mettre 2 par assiette
ouais on va peut-être prendre de grandes
assiettes n'ont pas de titre ouah c'est
bien voilà il fait réduire ma sauce ah
ben on va attendre un petit peu la wii
la socialie et pour ça le beurre est là
pour l'y ai oublié surtout dans les
nouvelles cuisines mal belle cuisine un
nombre beaucoup de beurre pour lier ça
ça va faire très grave tout ça quand
même à l'andouillette le savez que la
tambouille et c'est geneviève une
précision l'andouillette à la fraise de
veau c'est vraiment la meilleure elle
est plus cher d'ailleurs à les cacher
que l'on sait pas l'orgueil est bon on
va pas critiquer vendus est de force est
bon si mais disons s'ennuyer de fraise
de veau est quand même plus cher
obligatoirement puisque beaucoup plus
cher que le pop c'est quand même moins
grand voilà là est bien rodé
en fait j'ai goûté sel alors goûtez-moi
ça et aujourd'hui à des nouvelles je me
précipite
moi j'aime beaucoup
très bonne elle est pas grave du tout
nous voulions pas pierre qu'on en a
encore dans l'oeuf ou non alors allez on
essaie l'année on continue alors celle
de bison dans le four là en train de de
cuir façon à de gamme un bon quart
d'heure aussi la wii ouais alors dans le
four
normalement ça qu évidemment un petit
peu plus un peu fou un peu plus vite
mais on doit mois sont occupées l'an on
another day est gardée comme elles sont
colorées en restant très belles sont
confirmés h la pure disons qu'on pour sa
fuite tous les côtés à la fois dans sa
vie dit la gamme beurre dans la poêle
j'annulais retourner régulièrement et on
va faire une petite sauce moutarde
rajouter un petit peu de pour ajouter
avec vous quand même à sion ventures
alors voilà à soupe thunder
je suis gardé tout son parce que des
fois j'en ai quand même beaucoup à la
main généreuse dire au monde en juillet
et puis garder
oui donc je fais ma sauce moutarde en un
petit goûter à présent
je vais faire revenir un petit peu
d'échalotes dans mon beurre décidemment
j'ai grillé 1 en juillet alors que la
manche des grilles et qu'il faut faire
attention sur le gris c'est au gris soit
pas trop chaud pour pas l'andouillette
soif prier tout de suite comme des héros
carso est là le castrais délit coop
toujours pareil la sitcom frêche alors
qu'hier moi je mets de la crème fraîche
pour aller plus vite il ya des gens qui
mettent du fond de veau liés bon moi je
suis pas amateur
maintenant il faut rester sur les
produits naturels et je mets un peu de
moutarde de meaux grain oui un jeu
disons bonne ou moutarde anciennes alors
avoué ça va très vite et nous présenter
nos andouillettes
qui peut le saladier d'accord à lyon pas
sûr de les disposer façon artistique
elles sont belles elles n'ont pas éclaté
or c'est magnifique bon alors que ce
conseil at its as moutarde est prêt je
conseille aux médailles va vous faites
votre ampli y est à la moutarde regarder
si elles sont belles c'est de mettre la
petite sauce en saucière
comme ça les gens freinent la laisse ce
qu'ils veulent alors qu'il soit là
d'accord et on l'a même pas besoin
social on peut le prendre là donc je
mettrais un petit peu de sauce
simplement au bord de l'assiette de mon
ami alors on le met sur le côté pour pas
le mettre dessus ça sert à rien comme ça
les gens prennent la moutonne la sauce
moutarde qui veulent soit bien merci
aujourd'hui c'est exceptionnel on a
goûté de recettes voire goûtez-moi ça
[Musique]